i've been telling my followers and i
think this is just important for people
to do is if what you're viewing on
social media is making you feel worse
then you have to stop looking at it
social media also caters to what you
click on so if you're like okay this was
kind of interesting and it's this click
baity video that makes your outlook of
the world more negative it's just going
to keep showing you those things because
you press on them so you have to think
about how you want your life to be
surrounding yourself with resentful
people whether or not you're in the like
red pill community if it's making you
resentful especially towards the
opposite sex too whom you're going to
have to have a relationship with if you
want to have a family maybe you
shouldn't be watching content that makes
you resentful and then potentially stops
you from having a relationship and a
family maybe watch something more
positive it's important right especially
for kids or teenagers who get into it
early